[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy monday morning
welcome to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
there's a lot of developments
with putin
russia and ukraine the ue
um some banks in china
some airplanes
it's all it's all part of the show here
um as as the world stands behind ukraine
so we will see we will see what what uh
what transpires here obviously um you
guys know that there's talks
in belarus between ukraine and russia
uh rather that's another ruse from putin
or not we will see
we also we also see that switzerland
i think rachel bitkoffer tweeted
if uh switzerland cuts you off
[Laughter]
if switzerland cut you off financially
you are you're definitely [ __ ]
screwed good morning to everyone uh
debbie's here carter's here kathy is
here
uh robin hello good morning patty ann
mj everyone is here
welcome welcome welcome to the show
uh it is it has been a a a weird weekend
i you know i i actually thought that
putin
before he invaded you know weeks ago
when the threat was you know seen
imminent
you know maybe this guy's got another
10 years five years to rule russia if he
would want to
right
he invades
ukraine
with no with all the aggression right
there's there's no clapback or anything
like this no matter what kind of
propaganda they want to send which by
the way speaking of russian propaganda
the ue has banned
uh rt and sputnik the the russian state
tv channels
which i don't know that we shouldn't do
that here in america
but you know that's neither here nor
there maybe we'll get into that topic
today
but i thought
i thought putin probably had five ten
years before the invasion a week or two
before
left to rule russia
as he invaded last week i thought well i
meant this guy
he's got 18 24 months tops
tops
every hour that ticks by
takes
not just
weeks but months
off vladimir putin
at this point um
vladimir putin is headed down the road
of a typical tyrant
this is typical for tyrants
now i don't know exactly what's causing
this i think there's something
underlining that's causing the the
self-destruction of putin here i don't
know if it's his absolute delusion
i don't i don't i don't know if it's the
isolation from coronavirus we've seen
him we've seen him where he won't get
within you know a thousand feet of
another human being
i mean we've seen his generals the other
day when he was sitting with his
generals
there was this a thousand foot long
table
he's at one end
and his generals are sitting right next
to each other on the other and they set
the cameras up in a way that makes it
seem like they're sitting right next to
each other but
they're not
they're not
he's delusional he's scared
um it we'll see what these talks in
belarus bring today
but you know this may be another putin
ruse
um the oligarchs have to be really
banging at putin's door here because not
only
not only can they not uh get their money
but they can't even get on a goddamn
plane in the ue they bl banned all air
travel all every single one
russian air travel
it doesn't matter what it is it can't
land it can't fly it can't do nothing it
can't fuel if you're a russian aircraft
in the ue
you are not an aircraft anymore
you are a [ __ ] paperweight
now the world is isolating
putin
which is going to put pressure on putin
in his own country now a lot of people
are saying well you're punishing the
russian people well
let me be clear about something
there's no other people that will
pressure putin and his regime
than the russian people and they have
been
they have been we've seen we've seen
images
in russia of dissidents in the streets
putin dissidents in the streets risking
their lives to protest this war with
ukraine
which is bound to destroy
their country
this morning we see the stock market
can't even open
the ruble is down over 30 percent it's
crashing
which good for the ruble
good for the rest of the world banks
aren't allowing them to do anything
which you know it really big you know i
kind of think about this
over the weekend at cpac we seen grandpa
poopy pants
the cheeto dust mobster
give give more
flaccio to
putin
continue to talk about how putin's great
now putin's smart and his great real
estate deal with ukraine is [ __ ]
idiot
something something makes me believe
that possibly these sanctions of these
oligarchs
you know maybe that money isn't ending
up in the pockets
of certain people here in this country
you know maybe someone with the name
putin
i don't know
all right excuse me trump you see i get
those confused
you see how i get those confused
oh man
in this situation the entire world is
standing against putin
and it really does it really does say a
lot about the republican party here in
this country and there was images coming
out of cpac as well they were trying to
they were trying to do their damnedest
they're trying to do their damnedest to
turn to turn the narrative around that
conservatives and cpac and republicans
are anti-putin that with no avail
when you go as far in as you go in and
you put in with putin the way that the
republican party in this country has
done that you cannot undo it
what the [ __ ] did you think was gonna
happen
did you really think that putin was
gonna be measured
in his [ __ ] maniacal [ __ ]
tyrannical ways
did you really think that this murderous
[ __ ] dictator was gonna make sure
that your political party could stand on
a platform of putin
you dumb [ __ ]
and we should make them pay the price
you don't get to tuck tail and run and a
lot of them aren't even tucking tails a
lot of them double them down we've seen
we've seen general dunfuck
on trey trey gowdy's show
on fox news
one of trump's dod officials
basically saying well we should let
russia russia should be able to take
whatever territory they want
it doesn't matter we should stand out of
their way and let putin take any
territory they want
the united states nato and anyone else
shouldn't stand in putin's way it really
does seem like putin's puppets are
desperate to remain his play toys
i wonder i wonder why that is
i wonder why when the world is in the
situation that it's in right now and the
entire world is standing
with ukraine and against putin
and it's not even standing against
russia at this point really i mean
everyone's cheering on the russian
people who are protesting
who are saying no to war they're
chanting no to war no to war is what
they're chanting in russia being
arrested god knows what happens after
arrest they're arrested and then who
knows if we'll ever know that
there's brave russian people
standing with ukraine and standing with
the world
putin is the [ __ ] maniac
and it seems to be that there's plenty
maniacs here to stand behind putin
and it only makes you wonder is it
financial is there compromise you know i
don't have [ __ ] i don't know
what is it
this cannot be
i mean i believe that there's a [ __ ]
p-tape there's gotta be a [ __ ] p-tape
it just there has to be
there can't not be a [ __ ] p-tape
and the reason why i believe that is
because he says there isn't one
but this cannot this cannot be
the underpinning
of one single p-tape
there's something much more delusional
something much more
at the heart of the fabric
of why putin is desperate and scared
delusional
now
i believe putin probably had 18 to 24
months
when he was on the border
when he was on the border of ukraine
since he's invaded done what he's done
kill civilians
there's reports last night that they
were
bombing nurseries in schools luckily
that those ukrainians have seek shelter
in
in air raid shelters and bomb raid
shelters
so there wasn't as many casualties
but vladimir putin is hellbent
hellbent
on making sure the world knows that he's
a [ __ ] tyrant
and who knows what these talks
out of belarus
will give us today again i believe this
is probably another putin ruse
just to prolong the process try to pump
out as much propaganda as he had can
but the pressure is on
the economy and russia is going to fall
the ruble is worth nothing he can't
access his his war chest you know
there's reports of putin uh piling up
cash
almost in advance of this event
of him
seeking ukraine which
there is so much in the lead up to this
and and
the [ __ ] boneheads and the gqp
want to act like this is biting's fault
it's biden's war biden's not fighting
this war the american the american
troops aren't fighting this war the
ukrainian people are fighting
they're standing up for their country
the russians attack the ukraine capital
the republicans attack
our capital
so we have a lot to talk about in the
[ __ ] list roundup today
i believe gabe is going to join us at
the bottom of the hour
for 30 minutes or so
but there's a lot of video to show a lot
of stuff to get to some some of it very
very sickening some of it heartwarming
some of it funny
um so strap on your seat belts
i guess you'd say
for today's show
because you're you're gonna want to stay
tuned for the whole two hours um and
those of you out there that are
listening to the audio version
because we are going to show some video
today and i'll do my best to describe it
but you're definitely going to probably
want to head over to the tubes of you
and check out the
the video version
of this
and i know
i know a lot of people has expressed
this morning
the concern
of nukes
and
and nuclear war
and we talked about this a bit on friday
with rachel bitkoffer
and hopefully we'll have rachel on uh
later on in this week we always like to
bring rachel on
and maybe there's more developments
but putin's scared
he is terrified
you can see that again when he's sitting
at the table with his generals and he
has to sit a thousand feet away from his
own generals
this is not going to end well for putin
and i posted a picture
on twitter
with a man holding a sign
that says
we just skip to the part where you kill
yourself in a bunker
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
thank you for joining us
thank you for joining us we got a lot of
stuff to get to let me go to the
timeline first
let's go to the timeline
uh
russia is taking a lot of losses
um here is some of the losses that
they're taking here let this sink in uh
putin has lost more troops in ukraine in
the last three days than the u.s lost in
afghanistan in 20 years um this is a
russian army that is not prepared for
this war probably
we've we've seen a lot of troops uh
videos of troops crying as they capture
some of these uh
uh some of these vehicles these military
vehicles
uh let's see
uh
we'll come back to this this is a doug
ducey we talked about this on the bone
end of the week but i think it's uh
relevant again because when wendy rogers
is back in the news this morning and
[ __ ] bonehead and doug ducey
supporting her i wonder if he still does
it is shameful and disgraceful
uh as caitlyn says uh let's see here
a spirited exchange between the russian
ship and georgian
maintenance ship
um this is a great video let's um
there's got one point two m a one point
one million views um this is uh let's
see is this the one with the uh with the
subtitles
it looks like the russian
[Music]
he's saying here are you the russian
ship are you the russian ship i've seen
the one with the subtitles
are you russian
[Music]
so basically what he's saying here is if
you need few you can go [ __ ] yourself um
is what he says here um here's the
translation i think up above uh we we
refuse to refueling you um
and the assistant captain of georgia
says russia ship go [ __ ] yourself uh the
the russians here were running on fuels
looking for a refueling
and this uh maintenance ship and this
georgian maintenance ship told them to
go [ __ ] themselves so it's not it's not
just us here in this country that are
sick and tired of these [ __ ] russians
it is not it is not
uh
here's another um
part of the nuclear clay higgins says
you millennial leftists who never lived
one day under nuclear threat can now
reflect upon your woke sky
what does that mean
what does that mean you you made quite a
non-binary fuse to save the world from
intercontinental ballistic
tweets a dictionary here trolls drags
clay higgins here we're not entirely
sure what this tweet is supposed to mean
we're literally the dictionary
we are literally the dictionary
they're not they don't know what it's
supposed to mean they're literally the
dictionary
even the dictionary is trolling higgins
something about nuclear i don't know
nuclear threat woke sky intercontinental
ballistic tweets
what in the [ __ ] is this guy on
is this the crack maybe this is the
crack that donald trump jr was talking
about this weekend on stage you know
he's [ __ ] obsessed with hunter biden
absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with hunter
biden i mean he can't he can't make one
[ __ ] sentence
he can't form one goddamn sentence
without being obsessed about how joe
biden loves his son right that's what he
that's what he's [ __ ] so concerned
about
god i wish my dad loved me as much as
hunter biden's dad loves him
i mean that's what it's about it's got
to be at this point it's not about
hunter biden being a crackhead i mean i
mean i'm sure don jr would really would
love to do drugs with hunter biden
i mean maybe i thought that was at one
point that was what was going on
i don't know i thought maybe he wanted
to be you know get high buddies
hunter biden's not all uh you know
sunshine and rainbows folks
he's not
but joe biden knows that joe biden
loves his son you know regardless i mean
most people even if their kids
you know have troubles in their life
even if they have struggles
most parents
love their kids unconditionally but it
seems as if
don's a little
a little upset
about and he called hunter buying a
crackhead and i'm just wondering here of
clay higgins
with this with this whatever this is is
on crack is he on crack
is he on crack
uh caitlyn says epic just epic drag his
ass
yes thank you very much
for the tweet
let's go to fred because fred
clay higgins literally getting dragged
by the dictionary
oh my god
dictionary
coming in an
epic troll epic troll let's see what
else we got here on the timeline
okay gabe says spoiler or alert
peacekeepers don't attack innocent
civilians
so this is kind of the narrative
of oh he's just a peacekeeper
there's you know i've been getting this
a lot in my threads have you guys
noticed this in your thread like you
post some kind of you know [ __ ] russia
post right and then there's some kind of
[ __ ] bot or something that comes in
with a youtube video they're like oh
watch this youtube video for the truth
or some [ __ ]
right have you seen this
have you have you seen this
it pops up oh for the truth for the
truth
look at this youtube video it'll
convince you that you can't see with
your eyes of what the reports are it's
really [ __ ] dumb
uh anthony walker
the temporary ukrainian
i don't know if you guys know anthony
walker the bulletproof medic
but he has apparently um went to ukraine
to
help with the ukrainian effort there um
he's sending a picture here he says holy
[ __ ] so many people wanted to help the
ukraine that there's a traffic jam going
into the country
people are biking in you can see the
person on the bike here this is so
amazing
this seems like a lot of help
um
that is coming to ukraine's aid
uh he's got a video here of a also a
supply ship
delivering supplies to the ukrainian
army
so hopefully we can keep track of
anthony hopefully he stays safe over
there and
all the good intention he has i'm sure
we'll
get there
um
midas touch says the official gop
twitter account is indistinguishable
from the propaganda coming from russia
that should tell you everything traders
might just touch calling um the gop
twitter account traders
look
i don't know if you know this uh
of course they banned russian tv in the
uk in the in the european union
in the eu
but pretty much fox news
is real to real
on russian state tv rt and and sputnik
it's uh it's it's indistinguishable the
the policies look all the way back like
i said earlier putin and the republicans
have been planning this for [ __ ]
years in 2016 at the republican national
convention trump and his campaign
made sure
to make sure that that the united states
the policy would not be to arm ukraine
and then you have this
general dumb [ __ ]
on trey gowdy's fox news show
saying we shouldn't arm them we should
just let putin take as much territory as
he wants
hell
let that let him go into poland let him
go into europe let him take the uk
just let putin have it
sounds familiar sounds sounds like
fascists gonna fascist huh
uh rachel says damn when the swiss are
are willing to freeze your assets
you done [ __ ] up bro
yeah come on man with the swiss
look when the swiss are like nope sorry
[ __ ] you're it's too much
it's too much
it's way too much
even the swiss get grossed out and they
[ __ ] start taking your money
oh my god it's getting real
really [ __ ] fast too
like it's bad it's really [ __ ] bad
okay
mayo one of our favorites i think mayo
mayo is here i believe
mayo says putin has dug his own grave
well
you know i think i think that's true he
may have dug his own bunker here
uh now i'll probably find that picture
soon thank you mayo for your tweet
everyone i am so happy to have mayo uh
her original account back mayo is spicy
and she got her original account back so
everyone go um re-follow mayo if you
haven't i'm sure you have already but
you know
okay uh minus minus mighty matt um
has uh i want to point this out and give
him a shout out uh i was asked to write
something for bad brad
and i'm very proud of it
uh on the ringside report i believe it's
a must read for any ally and especially
those developing all the anti-war memes
right now
um
special thanks to
archie's gay dad for his editorial help
so go check out the article for matt
uh give matt some support
and uh take it take a look at his
article
it's on the timeline there so just
scroll down and
and uh see what matt had to say in his
write up for the ringside report bad
brad's ringside report
give him a shout out there uh i guess dr
oz wants to uh debate dr faunchi i guess
this is a [ __ ] this is what we're
gonna do
really
this th this this
this is what we're gonna do
all the [ __ ] that we got going on
and dr oz the non-doctor oz thinks he's
gonna [ __ ]
debate dr fauci's if dr fauci would give
this [ __ ] two [ __ ] seconds
come on now
someone call the [ __ ] home office and
reset the timeline please unplug that
[ __ ] and plug that son of a
[ __ ] back in this is [ __ ] ridiculous
now we even have to [ __ ] talk about
that i even have to say this [ __ ] into a
microphone
that dr oz is gonna [ __ ] debate dr
fauci get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
i found this on instagram
and i said found on instagram you figure
it out what is this
what is this
i've seen this i'm like what the [ __ ]
read the shirts it said uh it's for all
the used listening
it's it's it looks like a basketball a
high school basketball game
and it's two old dudes and t-shirts
ones
one looks very similar to moscow mitch
the other one looks very similar to
putin's little [ __ ] donald trump
and they're wearing shirts that say i'd
rather be i'd rather be a russian than
democrat
i don't know if this is [ __ ] real i
mean obviously this is not real in that
moscow mitch and
donald trump weren't at i mean they
wouldn't go to any kind of regular event
like this with you know the pores around
them right they wouldn't go to event
with all the pores around them in the in
the basketball stands no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way would they do that no
[ __ ] way
but i i said you figured out it i don't
know what this means i mean it's the
t-shirts say i'd rather be a russian
than a democrat i i don't know that i
don't know if that's if that's really a
thing that these that you know whoever
photoshop mitch mcconnell's head and
donald trump's head on to these
[ __ ] i know that the shirt's
[ __ ] real
aren't the shirts [ __ ] i don't know
i have no idea i don't know these things
i'm just pointing out that i saw this on
instagram so i figured i'd post it here
to show you
because i'm confused
i'm confused is the shirt real
are we assuming that donald trump and
mitch mcconnell would go to a [ __ ]
high school basketball game with the
poor's
you know regulars regulars peoples
and if these shirts do exist do these
people wear this [ __ ] out in public
are you [ __ ] kidding me
i mean god damn i got [ __ ] hats right
[ __ ] shirts
you know it's sometimes i wear that [ __ ]
in public
everyone else seems to like the hats
wear them and butt but would you wear
this [ __ ] shirt i'd rather be a
russian
than a democrat can you imagine what you
know what if that was your only [ __ ]
shirt you had to wear today
like after seeing what's happened with
putin
and how the world has turned against
putin
because you know again they're not
exactly turning against russia they're
turning against putin's russia
how even the chinese banks are saying
[ __ ]
oh my god
caitlin's saying the shirts are real
from a trump rally mj says they are real
wait wait wait these are from a trump
rat is this a is this this is a trump
rally here that's what this is this
isn't a basketball game this is a trump
rally
i mean it looks like a high school
basketball game right
i mean there is a lot of red maga hats
but i mean depending on where you're at
in the country
there could be a lot of red maga hats
but it could be that this is a
basketball game and the team's colors
are red
i don't know
i'm trying to figure this [ __ ] thing
out
uh caitlin says yep mj says yes so this
must be this must be
a a a [ __ ] trump rally or something a
nazi rally so you're saying this is a
nazi rally
oh my god
oh my god i'm glad i cleared this up i'm
glad i cleared the air on this picture
because i could not figure this out when
i seen this on the instagrams on the
grammy grams i don't i don't i know i'm
still trying to figure out instagram to
be honest with you i don't know much
about over there i've been posting uh
pictures of my tweets over there if you
guys haven't noticed there's some other
pictures of some other stuff if you
follow me on instagram you know you know
you're not seeing much more than what
you see on twitter but you know you can
go over there and follow me if you want
i i don't know maybe i'll figure out the
grammy grams or the instagram whatever
the hell it is over there maybe we'll
figure that out
oh my gosh this is [ __ ] ridiculous
okay let's move on here
um here is the uh here's putin's puppets
are desperate to remain his play toys
trey gowdy being a pitch excuse me trey
gowdy being a capitulating [ __ ] box
isn't surprising
let's watch this uh let's watch this
clip we got here
not want to do
in our usual effort to demonize him and
his country we need to remember that
ukraine is fourth from the bottom of 158
countries in the world
as corrupt russia is perhaps three or
four places above them this is not the
liberal democracy the shining example
that everyone says it is [ __ ] okay now
gabe gabe welcome gabe gabe came in just
at the time for this uh for this clip i
see we were watching the uh walmart uh
version of anderson cooper over here
right you know this is this is uh
colonel doug [ __ ] uh excuse me uh
mcgregor this [ __ ] trees in this
piece of [ __ ] um
how anyone could be how anyone could be
in the armed forces
uh and serve a dod and have the position
that this [ __ ] spewed on trey
gowdy's show well the worst part about
it is you're gonna see when i keep
playing this trey gowdy's yeah shaking
his head yeah you're right you're right
let's get to the best part here are from
it mr zielinski is jailed journalists
and his political opposition you know
what you know what's funny about that
part
when he says mr zelinski because even if
mr zielinski has done that okay right
the the really the really crazy [ __ ] is
that
this [ __ ] would love when trump
was president to jail journalists
yeah and to jail his poli lock her up
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me you can't
even make this [ __ ] up i know i know
they're all the thing i mean like not
only that but they're also like oh you
know it's the same [ __ ] that boom was
like has has put never done this and his
poo never tried to eat a dog
but you you kept out the parts or has
putin never tried to kill people who
were gay have his putin never tried to
assassinate journalists right these are
the things that like when they try to
use this as an example of oh actually
putin's not such a bad guy he's just
misunderstood no no no no that we're not
going with that [ __ ] right now
because we [ __ ] have the receipts of
what he's done it has been documented
we're literally watching him go in and
be like yeah yeah i'm keeping the peace
guys this is actually just like an
independent territory that russia
actually
owns and uh it just ignore the fact that
we're killing innocent people right now
like it's just just just ignore that
footage of us killing children or
running over someone or or what have you
you know
it's unbelievable and the fact that they
will continue to defend this just shows
the
the they you know some people are really
doubling down and you see that within
fox news obviously i will be curious to
see what tucker carlson says tonight if
he does a complete 180 and oh no no not
a complete 180 you believe that you
think you will i mean like you think
they'll dance around this thing like oh
what
what why is putin bad well maybe these
are the reasons why
i mean we've seen it you've seen it
you've seen it during the weekend it was
you know margery taylor green pushing
this whole thing of like you know starts
with i well i don't know nick fuentes
i've never seen oh we're going to get to
that [ __ ] we're going to get the energy
and then shifts over he's like but let's
talk about the real issue the real issue
is the invasion of ukraine which is
unjust and putin should be responsible
for that and you know whose fault it is
it's bidens and it's like i'm sorry how
did we how did we just tumble across all
of that and got to it's biden's fault
i'm sorry the last guy [ __ ] [ __ ] up or
he wasn't you know he was putin's puppet
and now joe biden you know i made a joke
last night was like holy [ __ ]
joe biden has been able to do this thing
without
uh harming
uh innoce or without harming american
lives and putting you know starting
world war three and he's been able to do
this on a fully transparent global scale
so people could see the hand that putin
is actually playing
and the funny thing is he did it while
he was sleeping in his basement you know
right like right right what yeah because
biden's so incompetent he's he he hates
americans he's going to put americans in
danger right and all this [ __ ] and
it just is the exact opposite the media
did the same thing with biden over the
last two months where they they they
acted like oh you're blowing stuff out
of proportion that putin's gonna do this
there's no way he's gonna do this and
that's why i keep saying that there's
there's an underlying condition here
that we don't know about i and i think
me and you talk privately uh yesterday
the day before that
that we there there seems to be
something that we
the world do not know that's happening
that they have information about
that is the reason why the
administration and nato was sure and
ukraine was sure that putin was going to
invade
um because it really doesn't make any
sense right it's unprovoked
he really he really there is there was
no real advantage for him to do this
when biden put him in the position that
the world knew exactly what was
happening right right and biden
the american government the state
department our diplomacy put putin in
the position that if he invaded everyone
would know why
right and really honestly it's making
it's making uh president zielinski the
president of ukraine look like an
ultimate hero here um now now rather now
rather that's what bears out or not you
know i guess the story will tell itself
but it really does make him look like a
hero because now he's able to rally his
people because there is truth behind
their action right there is truth behind
defending their democracy as imperfect
as it may be because that's what this
[ __ ] is saying here is that democracy
bad because democracy's not always
perfect that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's the putin propaganda that's the
[ __ ] that's what putin's trying to fight
for well democracy yeah democracy is bad
because if i'm not the one that's at an
advantage if i'm not the one who has the
final say and the power in a situation
then it's bad it's unfair it's unjust
and we need to change it so that and you
see that again with all of the
republican politics whether it's
gerrymandering redistricting uh you know
restricting the access to voting for you
know every american you know whatever it
might be or just the straight-up
gaslighting of like
january 6th that was just a tourist
visit right or it's like right you know
you look at literally what uh on the on
when uh
what russian officials have done you
know they're gaslighting be like we're
not killing people guys i don't know
why you think that that's crazy
right you know and it's like there's
footage of you doing is it's you know
it's not
not only that there's they brought their
own crematoriums to make sure
to burn the russian console like here's
the thing it's like all these things you
could say like oh well was it from this
year was it from another year it's like
regardless of whatever point in history
this happened it doesn't look good
whether that's old footage or videos or
that's current photos or videos like
either way the fact that these things
exist
aren't great right like whether using a
crematorium
uh for russian soldiers or ukrainian
civilians or soldiers like it doesn't
matter you look like a goddamn war
criminal because you are a war criminal
you are well innocent people bombing
them because you're trying to keep the
peace and these people are just living
in their homes just hoping that hey
maybe i'll wake up tomorrow and i'll
still be here without the [ __ ] fear
that some dude's gonna trap the truck
and try to drop a [ __ ] bomb on my
house right
right well all the while all the while
these oligarchies are getting squeezed
not only can they not fly they can't
[ __ ] move their bank accounts around
and maybe maybe that's why some
americans here are a little worried
because maybe they're they're [ __ ]
maybe their wallets depend on the
oligarchs money moving i don't know
maybe they'll maybe the republican party
will start you know a gofundme campaign
oh they're gonna [ __ ] need it
probably if the oligarchs money locks up
i mean
did you see the update this morning that
they did they were they detected
amounts of money that were assets that
were moving early early uh morning and
they started from the u.s side they
started to shut it down
no i haven't seen that i will uh if you
find that yeah just send me the link so
let's finish this video here because i
want to i want to finish dragging this
uh colonel our colonel doug [ __ ]
here i think we need to stay out of it
the american people think we should stay
out of it the europe that's a [ __ ]
lie by the way think we should stay out
of it that's a [ __ ] shot shipping
weapons and encouraging ukraine of
course you don't want to stop shipping
weapons of course you do you don't want
you don't want putin to be [ __ ] beat
hands to die in what is a hopeless
endeavor
so when you say say out of it you mean
no sanctions there's no military aid
just this is this is the [ __ ] gross
part where trey gowdy knows what this
[ __ ] is going to say trey
gowdy's not a dumb son of a [ __ ] he's
not a he's not he's not a dumb son of a
[ __ ] he knows he knows what this
[ __ ] is going to say but when he
asked him this question and then when he
shakes his head watch this [ __ ] it
pisses me off
the portion of ukraine they want to take
this [ __ ]
yes absolutely i i see no reason why we
should fight with the russians over
something that they have been talking
about for years we simply chose to
ignore it and more important the
population there is indistinguishable
from their own
you know
it's not one trey gowdy's shaking his
head that [ __ ] these
[ __ ] yeah just let putin have
it let him have poland let him have
germany let him have italy let him have
france [ __ ] let him have the uk and
while he's at it why didn't he just take
china japan why didn't he take australia
i mean
maybe northern africa i mean this sounds
all [ __ ] familiar right
fascist or gonna [ __ ] fascist and
they they [ __ ] love it they [ __ ]
love the fascism they love it oh my god
do they love it and i don't know if it's
because there's compromise i don't know
if it's because there's they're relied
on the [ __ ] oligarchs money dumping
into their bank accounts i haven't
figured it out because this is
completely un-american and for an
american colonel to [ __ ] say this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] treasonous in my [ __ ]
book yeah that's all i'm trying to say
all right i sent you two links do the
second one first because it's the guest
that uh trey has on
that just debunks everything he has to
say uh yes this is um
uh uh uh
jennifer griffin i've watched this clip
okay here's the clip well thank you
sorry it's gonna be a little weak
because it's i feel like i need to
correct
some of the things that colonel doug
mcgregor just said because and i'm not
sure 10 minutes is enough time to do so
because
by the way i want to correct her here
it's colonel [ __ ] doug [ __ ] yeah
yeah
in what he just said and talking about
the west and nato vilifying putin and
sounding like an apologist for putin and
talking about look at that [ __ ] smug
smirk on his face
i don't think anyone that i've spoken
well because he knows he he he knows why
he did what he did right
he knows he knows what that [ __ ] that
putin sycophant he knows what that
[ __ ] trump humping [ __ ] was
gonna say before he said it why fox news
would have these [ __ ] traitors on
their tv in the first place that
[ __ ] belongs on russian tv he
belongs on sputnik not on american news
channel for sure i don't care if he's
with trump's dod or not maybe that
speaks more to the trump administration
and how they were running [ __ ] in the
first place and why putin invaded
ukraine now
here at the pentagon or elsewhere in uh
western intelligence believes they know
how far poop wants to go and i think
that the world has seen what putin is
capable of and to blame uh nato
membership for what we've seen putin
unleash we've seen from putin's own
words that he is talking in zara's terms
from a 18th a 19th century view of uh
empirical in imperial russia so those uh
what he just said was so distorted that
i do feel that our audience needs to
know the truth in terms of putin i've
known uh and seen
vladimir putin operate since 1999 when i
was based in moscow for fox it's where i
started my career with fox and vladimir
putin is a former kgb agent he's been
laying the groundwork for this and he's
been uh whether it was invading
georgia in 2008 we've talked about the
invasion in 2014 the kind of appeasement
talk that colonel doug mcgregor who
should know better because [ __ ]
colonel [ __ ] he was the one who was
advising uh president trump to pull all
u.s troops out of germany that kind of
ha i wonder i wonder why now i wonder
why now because you know
it seems it seems to be that if you were
going to go past ukraine and into europe
and and past poland where where where
would you be like on a map i guess for
for peacekeepers right for peacekeepers
out there what and freedom fighters you
[ __ ]
going past those borders i wonder why i
wonder why trump wouldn't want american
troops in those regions as putin was
going to lay waste acro our peace excuse
me
lay peace across those borders i wonder
i wonder what the purpose was of those
troops not being in germany those
of
[ __ ]
and weakness is what made putin think
that he could actually move into a
sovereign country like ukraine
takes a lot yeah yeah yeah jennifer here
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and i wonder
how long it'll take for jennifer gr uh
griffin to be to be fired
from fox news here i live fact checking
that [ __ ] trees in this piece of [ __ ]
on air
um i wonder i wonder how many phone
calls from the former guy were made the
fox news when she oh yeah
that [ __ ] in between diet coke
sessions
and in a big mac
caitlyn's saying here that uh breaking
the ruble
is at a record low worth less than one
cent oh my god
oh my god they tore it apart this
morning
yeah it's uh it's pretty impressive you
know i said it yesterday uh putin has
become his own worst enemy and with
doing like he has somehow taken
countries that have remained neutral
to hold a position
right
he has somehow involved people
switzerland switzerland's like
yeah they're like they're like okay this
is [ __ ] up like we were through some
[ __ ] during like world war ii and in
world war one and like all like we've
we've always like uh
we don't want to touch it because the
[ __ ] is is is tainted uh and we need a
safe haven for people and
this weekend they're like nah [ __ ] it
man this is crazy like
we it's not even it's not even worth
like like liter literally literally the
oil because the oil is a big contention
this morning we've seen the oil like uh
uh uh everyone's cutting off the [ __ ]
oil like nope done
you're [ __ ] done no more [ __ ] oil
no more russian oil anywhere even
china's like nope not doing the russian
oil thing we're not doing that
i mean yeah what what do they have to
sell if they can't launder money and
they can't sell oil
what's left ah
i don't know i i honestly don't know
i mean that's that they have a they have
a washing a money washing machine
and they have and they have oil wells
yep like that's that's what they got
yeah i don't know i mean it's uh
yeah i don't i don't i mean i honestly
don't know what the other exports are
from russia uh also i i do want you know
what i want to get on a soapbox for a
second here go ahead the people that are
are saying let's ban
russian vodka let's ban russian products
isn't that
that's probably the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard
and i'm gonna straight up say that i
don't agree with it because here's the
thing does putin
single-handedly own these things does he
own these private russian companies like
this is this is the same [ __ ] that
happened when when covet hit and it was
like oh wuhan virus and da da and this
all [ __ ] we should blame all asians for
something like a virus right this is
again blaming all russians for something
that putin did now putin does not
uh represent the russian population
right we've seen that this past week and
weekend they were literally putting
their lives at risk to to protest what
putin had done and to speak up to say
that this was not right this is wrong
okay now to the same people who are like
oh you know on those streets like raise
your hand or like retweet this and all
this [ __ ] if you want to you know
boycott or ban russian
uh vodka that doesn't make any sense
that that literally makes no sense i
don't know who you're you're hurting or
who you're helping outside of the fact
that people don't know where the vodka
actually comes from people like oh
should ban grey goose and it's like well
fragrance isn't from [ __ ] russia
but anyway the point being is that i
hear people that are doing these like
what i see as
performative activism they're like let
me ban this let me ban that well
that's not
that's not gonna do anything against
putin okay that doesn't matter that is
that is that is
pointless it is useless you're putting
your effort into something that does not
matter and actually might be and end up
hurting a group of people that don't
align with putin so this whole thing
like i'm dumping out the vodka and all
that [ __ ] that doesn't doesn't mean
[ __ ] and it's so dumb it's the same
thing it's the same thing as when when
uh the colin kaepernick was kneeling
jerseys and they were burning jerseys
exactly it's the same type of
performative activism or or protesting
that you want to be like oh man i want
to protest this by you know dumping out
the vodka like i'm a store owner i'm
dumping out the vodka that you literally
also paid for right now or losing money
on right but you know okay yeah
and and you don't get to get drunk what
the [ __ ]
it is dumb it is dumb and so i just want
to say that so so that's a good point
and to everyone out there to to
what you can do what you can do is
participate in democracy and the reason
why that is so [ __ ] important is
because that's why putin's invading in
the first place is he's terrified of
democracy he's completely terrified of
it and really honestly i was reading
some um some threads this weekend is is
that um
that that this this is uh an operation
that has been going on since really 2000
prior to 2008 um before he invaded
georgia right yeah i mean this has been
this has been putin's plan for a long
time he's been working up to this and
again i don't know what it is about the
i don't know what it is about that we
don't know that is the reason why putin
is so desperate and delusional and he's
willing to act on those things as a
tyrant here but it really is leading to
the end of his rope here um i we got
another tweet that you sent um
calan collins that you retweeted here it
says the u.s announces they're cutting
off russia's central bank uh banning u.s
citizens banning u.s citizens companies
from doing business with them
effectively
mobilizing any assets from the central
bank of the russian federation held in
the u.s or by u.s persons and then
here yeah yeah this is the follow-up
the white house says that they're
announcing this decision before u.s
markets open after learning from allies
that the russian central bank was
attempting to move assets and there
would be a great deal of asset flight
this am so people were trying to pull
money out of that bank right i wonder
i wonder if any of those [ __ ]
receipts say i don't know i don't like
the last name uh maybe starts with a t
you know i don't know i'm just saying it
really it really does seem kind of funny
that a lot of these trump allies and and
and uh these trump sycophants are really
concerned
about um you know all these sanctioned
on russia because they've been oh
these sanctions aren't gonna work you
remember that talk last right yeah yeah
this section is
and then you look at it and you're like
oh no no
it's actually like the fact that like
okay let's you know you go back to the
beginning you say yeah this didn't
happen as quickly as it should have when
it came to sanctions and likes trying to
you know
crimp the hose of of money flowing right
right it's it's gotten there
where we want if not all of it but most
of it and it didn't happen as quickly as
you wanted right okay we admit that but
when it started people were like this
isn't going to do anything biden's so
weak
this like he should do something well
dude the guy is [ __ ] playing chess
right now and he's coordinating efforts
with other people in the eu nato to try
to close off whether you know china and
india actually want to participate in
the vote like
we're peeling away at the [ __ ] that's
happening with those countries and their
allegiance to russia right like there's
there's little bits of momentum we're
taking baby steps to get there but now
it's compounding on itself over this
past weekend and we're getting to a
point where oligarchs like you know i'm
sure they're sweating putin i'm sure
he's in his bunker
i'm just gonna put it out there right
now
putin did not kill himself okay someone
else did right and if he did
you know the guy is delusional and maybe
he did i don't know but i'm just saying
like you know just like epstein he
didn't kill himself okay right right so
uh speaking of oligarchs have you seen
this uh bit of news here too oh is this
the uh the flight tracker yeah so this
is the flight tracker but you you know
that uh the eu
banned all russian flight so you can't
land
you cannot you cannot um
take off all planes um this is uh
automated uh account i'm gonna follow
this thing while i'm here um because
they've been tracking russian oligarch
jets all around the world like this
isn't just in europe they've been doing
it all around the world um and this one
here uh was from yesterday in the pm so
they're landing all these planes um but
it does it does seem significant that
they're tracking these things and not
only are these oligarchs not not have
access to their money they can't go
anywhere right i mean i guess they could
hop in a car on a bicycle yeah sure you
could you know you could you could be
like the poor's as they would say and
get into a bus and try to get out and be
like
you know refugee or whatever right and
do it that way right but
that really does show you take the
subway take this right yeah yeah just
like the common people you know but it
really does show you like the position
they're in they cannot fly they cannot
pay for anyone because they don't have
access and at the end of the day like
you put them in a position that they are
now up against the corner and only in
the only way to get out of that corner
is to take out putin because once
putin's out and we've like de-escalated
the situation then we see that russia is
not a threat or at least the world sees
that russia is not a threat and they go
okay cool we'll release the choke on the
financial institutions and the
restrictions in terms of flight now
whether the next person is as
bad or better than putin remains to be
seen but this whole conflict has
certainly uh accelerated the the
timeline of his retirement whether
that's him alive or not
well speaking of transportation
and uh these videos these videos [ __ ]
crack me up
how oligarchs could get around here i'm
just right like or the video of the
ukrainian guy who drives up next to the
tank that broke down you know and he
just starts uh trolling him and and
the other thing the other thing that
yeah so there's a there's another i'll
see if i can find it and send it to you
but there's another video there's
another post that i saw about how
uh ukraine has begun changing the signs
of directions on how to get to certain
cities right so oh so they're [ __ ]
with so they're lost which i think is
hilarious and so smart
well i mean you think they would have i
don't know like a map
i don't know yeah yeah
but i guess like if you think about it
these kids are like 20 19 20 21 they
don't yeah have you seen some of the
video like when they get them and they
supply [ __ ] and these guys are crying
right or they're on the phone or
something you know like i look at the
stuff and i say like oh yeah this is
[ __ ] crazy because they went in
with a different idea of what was
happening whether they were told they
were peace keeping peace i mean again
they've got family and connections to
ukraine and vice versa and so you know
you're sending well
you know that there's this and i'm not
going to talk about it a lot because
it's all [ __ ] yeah but but but the
russian people have been sold this bill
that there's some kind of genocide
happening in ukraine and that's why
putin's going in and that's why these
soldiers are saying
to stop this genocide which
there isn't any right but again
this is like the ars this is like the
arsonist starting the fire and then
being like hey okay let's send in like
i'm gonna come in and you know like hose
out the situation
well no well they want to pour gasoline
on it to burn it to the ground right
let's watch let's watch let's watch here
the oligarchs um next means of
transportation here in in russia or
ukraine
for those who just listening that can't
see um we'll play this over again uh
without the sound there is a there is a
there's a tractor um it's it's a big
tractor um not a small but a big tractor
um like towing away a russian tank here
as they run after it like
i don't know if that's the if that's
someone affiliated with the the the
farmer or if that's uh right if there's
a russian
you know what that reminds me of it's
it basically is the moment when you
don't pay your bills and right you get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] reboot reboed and the
guy's like don't care already hatch it
up right right uh
it's j i'm just doing my job man
don't be mad at me don't be mad at the
store and you're just catching it
getting repo down the street
so this farmer repo'd
repo the tank
oh my gosh uh the other the other video
i sent you is the the guy the you know
okay yeah okay uh let me give credit
here so we get uh full if we read it we
give credit so let's see uh let's see
what this is the the the latest one here
yeah okay let's see here let's get the
this is the uh the guy trolling is that
yeah so if you read the captions holy
[ __ ] there's nine and a half million
views how am i saying yeah yeah
okay let's let's see
guys pulling up alongside the tank
somebody's he's basically asking like
you know you guys broke down what does
he do they were saying like oh yeah
we're out of gas
and then he asked them if they need
directions
[Laughter]
and then he goes
maybe you guys should you know i'll give
you a ride
i mean you know the oligarchs uh
airplanes are down maybe the tanks are
in because they're running out of gas or
running on fuel like they didn't have
enough fuel to get in this country you
think like a country that has oil
like wells it they'd be able to just
like refineries that they would be like
hey we've got plenty of gas and oil to
to keep right
well again again like you think someone
would have got out a map and done like
okay well it's going to be 400 miles
it's going to be five hours also
you know i don't know like securely
would be able to use gps without giving
away your location to be like great we
got to just continue on this road for
like 100 kilometers then take a right
and go for 200 kilometers and then we're
there i mean really honestly
are we supposed to believe that russia
is just gonna crush not only ukraine but
nato when they can't even figure out
simple road trip things like this is
road trip and it's supposed to be an
easy sweep and this has turned out like
i was talking to yesterday you know i
said i don't know if this is how it's
ultimately gonna end out like is if
ukraine is going to be the victor in the
situation and be able to defend russia
or you know are they just slowing you
know kind of war of attrition are they
just slowing it down
or you know what will happen but i was
like
this very well could end up like you
know david versus goliath right and
obviously goliath being russia and david
being ukraine and
in many ways it's kind of leading to
that like at least that i the early idea
of that happening because it was
supposed to be late night run in boom
we'll get through and maybe by the next
day we'll be able to just like flood him
and we'll take over and now
that was thursday friday uh now we are
saturday sunday we're now into monday
and
they are still
zielinski and everyone else are still
holding off kiev so it's like
it's impressive and uh kind of a miracle
because
the proportion of russia versus ukraine
is uh
you know it's out one outweighs the
other so it's not like crazy but it's
crazy
i love the blinker the whole time the
blinker noise
but yeah if you read the if you if you
uh escape from here and then read the
caption this goes do you need a lift
you know where you're you're going then
just says russians russians russian tank
breaks down out of gas ukrainians ask do
you need a lift you know where you're
going then juggling ass maybe give
how about
we took you back to russia
uh maybe we'll go get the [ __ ]
tractor we'll go get the tractor with
all your ass i know i'm gonna repel this
tank oh [ __ ] man you can't make this
[ __ ] up you just can't and yeah you know
i would say this like i don't you know i
i i gotta jump but i do look at this
situation as like
social media whether used as propaganda
to
show things as they aren't or are
whatever uh it is a powerful tool in
terms of like
fighting the disinformation that putin
and his cronies have put up about this
conflict right we've got people that are
there saying like no no look at the [ __ ]
going down and here are some hilarious
moments and how they [ __ ] fell flat
on their face
so
well i i think you're right and thanks
for joining us uh for the time that you
had today gabe and we'll talk to you
soon we'll we'll talk to you tomorrow
have a good time we got some we got some
big news this week so yes we do we will
be able to get to that so we'll we'll
talk to you tomorrow have a good one
yep
uh so let's get back like uh some of you
guys are pointing out in the uh in the
comments here
the uh
the uh let's see we've got um
the gas and the food it looks like um
let's see
oh oh i know what it was the internet
the gps some of you guys were pointing
out the gps like maps
and how uh how you could get added to
maps and stuff like that and uh let's
see mj head
here we go mj says they can't use gps
because of hackers um and then uh kalyn
says anonymous has been hacking over 300
russian state government websites it's
like that that that might have a lot to
do with them not being able to use like
virtual maps
but regardless regardless when you're
when you're in a military operation you
generally have
most of the time
you generally have a a a situation
where you have a physical [ __ ] map
and you know where you're going and it's
not just like oh well you make a left on
this street you make a left on that
street you make a left on this street
like not that kind of [ __ ] map like a
geographical map as a wells road map
but they can't even figure out simple
road trip [ __ ] like you know we're gonna
need some gas and [ __ ]
this is this is a little ridiculous
um
let's go
uh okay here's the here's the uh over
the weekend let's go to some cpac stuff
here i'm on the cpac part of the uh the
timeline here
the fishing trip last night
with me went for a lot of money
see
if i were hunter biden i'd put that in
my pocket rather than going for a good
cause right they'd be a little different
but we can't do that right
that too
no i think
think about how bad things are going
right now i'm going to play off of that
okay sir
that the administration that currently
is in charge
wanted to put together a program to hand
out crack pipes because you'd have to be
on crack to think that they're doing a
good job okay
so here we are with this
[ __ ] buffoon of course we got to deal
with this guy over and over and over
again and keep doing with this guy
and donald trump jr guy standing on
stage is crackhead standing on stage
talking about crack pipe i mean you know
no better expert
at cpac really to talk about crack pipes
and donald trump jr don't you think i
mean come on they're like you know let's
talk about crack pipes but let's make
sure we book someone who knows a hell of
a lot of [ __ ] about crack pipes let's
make sure that's how we we frame that up
this guy is [ __ ] obsessed
this guy is [ __ ] obsessed with hunter
biden and hunter biden's laptop and
hunter biden's crack pipe
listen
democrats
aren't inviting hunter biden
to come on stage and speak
this [ __ ] charges money
the republicans charge money at
at fundraising events
for people to take pictures of this
[ __ ] crackhead donald trump jr booger
sugar junior
right
who in the [ __ ] out there would stand in
line
stand in line to take a picture with
hunter biden let alone pay two thousand
dollars to me in the same goddamn room
as him
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
this is absolutely [ __ ] ridiculous
that somehow donald trump you know again
maybe it's not so ridiculous if you
think about it
cpac has the [ __ ] crackhead
crackhead
aficionado
come and talk about crack pipes
i mean that kind of makes sense you know
i mean it would would it would make
sense
it would make sense if you were going to
make sure you got the crack pipe talking
on stages you'd have your crack pipe
expert
come and give the [ __ ] ted talk on
crack pipes
i mean who else would give this [ __ ]
i mean i guess his girlfriend kimberly
could
i don't know
i don't think eric is smart enough to
use a [ __ ] crack pipe maybe i don't
know
i'm just snowballing here but i'm just
saying it but maybe it does make sense
maybe i'm off my rocker here and it does
make sense that donald trump jr is
giving the ted talk on the crack pipes
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
you're just [ __ ] jealous you little
[ __ ] that your daddy that your daddy
doesn't love you and hunter biden's
daddy loves him get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ] now um here's another
sunday
uh uh sunday video from uh mitt romney
uh no need for comment i didn't i didn't
feel a need to comment here but
on the video but now i'm gonna comment
i'm gonna [ __ ] comment on this
because um everyone's cheering mitt
romney there's no need there's no need
to pat mitt romney on the back here but
let's watch this video and then we'll
talk about it
you talked several times during this
interview about the world seeing the
difference between good and evil i want
to bring that closer to home and talk
about something that congresswoman liz
chaney tweeted
yesterday about sitting republican house
members appearing at a white nationalist
gathering she said quote as
representative marjorie taylor greene
and paul gosar speak at this white
supremacist anti-semitic pro-putin event
silenced by republican party leaders is
deafening and enabling
all americans should renounce this
garbage and reject the putin wing of the
gop now okay so this is very important
and again you guys probably know my
stance on
on liz cheney you know everyone want to
make her into the hero that she might
might be a a hero for democracy
uh for the january 6 select committee
again
this is more clear evidence that liz
cheney is trying to get her party back
right she's trying to get the gop back
she's not worried about she's not
worried about democracy ultimately i
mean you know she's got to play into
that but she's wanting to drive wedges
right and we should let her drive wedges
that's what we should we should be
encouraging drive wedges
listen and me and rachel bickoffer
talked about it on friday and we'll
probably talk about it uh this week
later on after the state of the union
happens and we'll see their response
there
here's the thing
there are wedges to be to be had here
and we need to draw these wedges in
between them
uh liz cheney is giving clear evidence
that hey
it's gonna be easy to break up the
republican party and they're a
republican electorate here
fantastic let's do that
uh i think liz cheney has come to the
terms that you know it's gonna be
several election cycles before the
republican party is back on top
and uh
this putin thing is not you know the
trump thing was horrible but this putin
thing has not helped anything especially
when trump is behind putin and they
continue to stand by putin and where
it's probably because the money washing
machine trump relies on the russian
money washing machine here
that's why he's still with putin of
course that's shut down this morning
let's finish let's see what mitt
romney's response is
do you agree
absolutely uh liz cheney was
absolutely he does absolutely
as if in this moment right now and since
you had me on your show and i'm able to
definitively take a position now that
the position is there to take i will
take it right with that statement and
she's been right for a long time and i
also saw oh really she's been right for
a long time romney where the [ __ ] have
you been
where the [ __ ] have you been
uh that uh the ronald mcdaniel came out
with a statement as well uh uh talking
about how repugnant these white nasties
ronna mcdaniel he's got to throw in uh
ohrana romney yep specialists are the
first there's no place in and either
political party uh for this white
nationalism or racism it's simply wrong
uh it's it's uh as as you've indicated
speaking of evil uh it's evil as well
and uh and you know marjorie taylor
green and paul gosar i don't know them
but i remember get the [ __ ] out of here
marjorie taylor green and paul gozar you
don't know them mitt romney
is he seriously saying that we're
supposed to believe that he we have he
has no idea who marjorie taylor green
and paul gosar are
that he just [ __ ] forgot who those
[ __ ] nazis were
that on january 6 as he was running away
from the mob
after the evidence was shown in the
[ __ ] impeachment trial that he
doesn't know who marjorie taylor green
and paul goes are
who they are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me we're
supposed to believe this
[ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ] mitt romney
look i i'm all i'm all for and
everyone's gonna excoriate me oh you're
banging up on mitt romney you goddamn
right i am
you goddamn right i am why hasn't he
been yelling at the rooftops
why the [ __ ] didn't he make sure to vote
for voting rights why didn't he try to
pull chris kirsten cinema and joe
manchin over to make sure that the
filibuster was carved out for voting
rights if he's so goddamn concerned
about
marjorie taylor greene and paul gozar
and white nationalists taking over our
country
that the pro-putin pro-white nationalist
pro-nazi part of the gop
was taking over the country huh
why
[ __ ] out of here
minor that old line from the butch
cassidy the sundance kid movie where
where one character says morons i've got
morons on my team and i have to think
anybody that would sit down with white
nationalists and speak at their
conference was certainly missing a few i
keep iq points listen
here's the thing here's the thing the
morons on your team that's all [ __ ]
come on come on
you're still admitting that they're on
your team and they're just morons
and they're just [ __ ] they're just a
little silly they're just they're not
seditious
they're not treason this in any way
they're not trying to they're not trying
to bang up our constitution or anything
it's not like they they encouraged an
insurrection or anything
it's not like they encouraged to
overthrow the government of the united
states or anything not like that and
it's not like they continue to placate
to the part of the party that still
wants to commit a coup and still wants a
fascist state it's not like they're
doing they're just morons
mitt romney
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
if you really want to come on [ __ ]
cnn or msnbc [ __ ] wherever the [ __ ] you
go on
grow a set of [ __ ] balls
and tell the [ __ ] full truth
and excoriate them
damage them not this [ __ ] oh they're
they're just stupid because i'm going to
show you the [ __ ] trees and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that marjorie taylor green
did
and just more broadly the pro-putin
sentiment that you are seeing from some
corners of your party
here's the pro well all those people are
are changing their stripes as they're
seeing uh the the response of the world
and the political response here in the
u.s but how anybody
how anybody in this country
which loves freedom
can side with vladimir putin
which is an oppressor a dictator he
kills people
he he he imprisons his political
opponents uh he has been an adversary of
america at every
chance he's had everyone wants to give
mitt romney credit for back in the 2012
campaign
when he was uh running against barack
obama
he said that one of the biggest
the biggest threats to america the
geopolitical threat of putin
everyone wants to give him credit for
for saying that
um and here he is saying that he's a
murderous dictator and
you know all the [ __ ] the democrats have
been saying for years
and we're supposed to give him credit
now
now that he's saying well you know some
of them my party have backtracked
no you say they don't get to backtrack
that's what you say mitt romney they
don't get to take their words back
they don't not with the murderous
dictator tucker carlson mike pompeo
donald trump they don't they do not get
to take their words back they don't
they don't get to backtrack on putin
because now that they know that putin's
a piece of [ __ ]
it's unthinkable to me it's it's almost
treasonous
and uh almost
get the [ __ ] out of here i'm sick of
this son of a [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] almost treasonous
you piece of [ __ ] okay let's let's
continue on here uh porcupine cheeks
shows uh if russia a sign here i found
this on instagram as well if russia
stops fighting there will be no war
if ukraine stops fighting there will be
no more ukraine got it
you follow um
yeah okay um
now let's see oh here
here you go speaking of putin sycophants
that uh putin has um compromi on
probably
let's uh let's listen to uh arkansas
um little senator here little [ __ ]
senator because that's what he is as a
little [ __ ] let's listen to what tom
cotton has to say i'd like to you know
this guy is [ __ ] gay doesn't he look
like doesn't he look like a really a
really uh one of those you ever you
remember when your kid you got those um
those uh uh um
um
oh what's what's the the clowns you know
they're weighted at the bottom like blow
up and you could you could punch them
you know what i'm saying it's like a
like a kid's punching toy you know when
it goes down it comes back up it's like
[Laughter]
it looks like i mean i'm just saying he
kind of looks like one of those with
really big [ __ ] ears let's listen to
this stupid [ __ ] hopefully the ukrainian
army has anti-tank missiles that
president obama would not supply that we
did supply last time republicans were in
charge in washington
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen to this again listen to what he
said fully the ukrainian army has
anti-tank missiles that president obama
would not supply that we did supply last
time republicans were in charge in
washington you know what's funny about
that you know what's really funny about
that we actually had this whole big
thing it was a whole big thing in this
country
there was a president of the united
states and i don't remember his name
right off hand um but there was a
president united states that was
withholding weapons and withholding uh
military funding from the government
that you're talking about [ __ ]
and he i think i believe i i believe
i believe that he was a [ __ ]
republican and i think
might have been could be i don't know he
possibly could have been impeached for
the whole goddamn thing
for a quid pro quo
you give me this i'll give you military
aid you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and you voted
you voted senator you piece of [ __ ]
to not impeach him
that's why it's so urgent that we
continue to supply those weapons to
ukraine yeah i'm sure it's urgent now
condemn donald trump for those comments
now uh the george stephanopoulos here is
asking
senator [ __ ] why he can't condemn
donald trump for the comments the
comments are with the the uh where he's
in support of putin
um taking over ukraine kind of like
colonel [ __ ] was on trey gowdy's
show
george if you want to know what donald
trump thinks about vladimir putin or any
other topic i'd encourage you to invite
him on your show i don't speak on behalf
of other politicians oh you don't speak
on behalf of other politicians so you
don't you don't say what obama and
biden's intentions are you don't you
don't ever say that you don't ever speak
on their behalf and what their
intentions are you don't do that senator
the [ __ ] out of here and speak for
themselves i speak on behalf of
arkansans who i talked to this week and
no you don't no no you don't i i don't
think i don't think i'm the majority of
our kansas think that you speak on
behalf of them but yeah we'll we'll
[ __ ] skip over that part you are
appalled at what they saw in ukraine and
they want me
right now to fight in washington to
support those brave ukrainians right now
last week last week last week he was
fighting for putin
last week he was fighting for putin he
was rooting for putin
rooting for putin he was last week put
in for putin
tom cotton was
this week because he's seen poles down
in arkansas
that maybe maybe the good people down in
arkansas aren't so hip on a [ __ ]
murderous dictator taking over a
sovereign country
especially when they're the aggressor
not the peacemaker you dumb [ __ ]
now now just now this week
this week he's gonna do what he should
have done last week
you know
it is really kind of weird
that we did this dance for years for
[ __ ] five years we've done this dance
of these republicans acting like oh yeah
putin good putin good
because
it must be good because he's tough and
[ __ ] he's not [ __ ] tough we've seen
that the guy can't even get within five
uh 500 feet of his own generals he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] putin is
well
not surprising that a little [ __ ] like
tom cotton here would have been putting
in for putin now now that he realizes
that the world has snuffed this [ __ ]
out
and the world realizes who putin is and
the entire world is going to back
ukraine
and their efforts and stand with ukraine
and tell putin to go [ __ ] himself
and now now he's decided he'll be
against putin you're a senior member of
the republican party donald trump is the
leader of the republican party he said
last night again suggested that he'd be
running for president when fox news
asked him if he had a message for
vladimir putin he said he has no message
why can't you condemn that i feel quite
confident that if donald that if barack
obama or joe biden said something like
that you'd be first in line to criticize
him
again george if you want to talk to the
former president about his views or his
message you can have him on your show my
message to vladimir putin is quite clear
he needs to leave ukraine unless he
wants to face how does anyone vote for
these
these [ __ ] sniveling little bastards
how
how do you do it how do you [ __ ]
wake up in the morning okay here's
here's that uh that picture i was
talking about earlier that i want to
show
it says on the sign here
dear putin let's speed up the part where
you kill yourself in a bunker i'm just
reading the picture here
the sign i'm just reading the sign i'm
not saying i'm advocating for it you're
saying this is this is a hell of a
message on the sign that's being printed
that's all i'm saying
and i'm not sure exactly where this is
at but
you that seems uh seems significant
okay um here's a [ __ ]
oh ronnie johnson these guys just can't
stop either here's another [ __ ]
who is put in with putin until putin
wasn't cool no more let's find out
wanting to live in peace and freedom
um but i think we do need to take a look
at what all led up to this i don't think
vladimir putin would have moved on
ukraine look we're not gonna you don't
wanna you don't you don't wanna find out
what all led up to this you don't wanna
know that ron johnson you piece of [ __ ]
because all that i mean you spent so
many [ __ ] fourth of july barbecues
with putin
i mean what did you guys have [ __ ]
hot dogs
brats was the hamburgers what were you
eating over there on 4th of july what
kind of barbecue were you eating
did you did you hold hands while you
watched the fireworks for independence
day
you piece of [ __ ] were not for the
weakness
displayed uh certainly by the blind
administration but also by the western
general and i'm certainly hoping that
colonel vidman
uh adam schiff nancy pelosi who use
ukraine as a pawn
in their impeachment uh travesty
ah yeah yeah remember how that colonel
vinman used it as a pawn and his impeach
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
what did colonel venman had to gain
what was it you piece of [ __ ]
so that you so he could have you and his
in your [ __ ] mouth get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] are also
recognizing reflecting how they weakened
ukraine uh weaken the west weaken
america by the divisive politics that
they play
uh
there's there's much blame to go around
but in terms of the atrocities that that
falls squarely on the shoulders of
vladimir putin and his cronies they oh
uh
ron johnson will be cut out of the uh
the circle the putin circle jerk
soon after those statements i'm sure
okay let's move on um
let's see
there's uh
some more of that i wanted to show i
thought i had some more cpec
yeah here's another seat back here aaron
aaron had this cpac video this is great
this is great you want to see some more
cpec [ __ ]
there's another scene from cpac this is
a
some kind of conservative pastor or some
stupid [ __ ] i don't know he's gonna give
tots and pears listen to this listen
this i'm gonna ask all of you to do a
favor yeah even if it's a little
uncomfortable even if it's a little
uncomfortable he's gonna ask him to do a
favor here even if it's a little
uncomfortable i don't know if that means
like physically or
you know like financially
maybe politically maybe emotionally i
don't know i don't know what's that what
i don't know what level of uncomfort
that he's talking about here but
let's let's let's hear
you with your spouse is here
so the single people not need to pay
attention only the ones with the spouses
right only married folk are supposed to
pay attention to this why i don't know
it's very weird when you hear what he
says but let's listen down
and give a prayer
for what's taking place in ukraine
so he only wants the married people
which is kind of weird right like why
wouldn't a single person want to kneel
down and pray for ukraine what's
happening in ukraine because he doesn't
say pray for ukraine he says pray for
what's happening like pray to make sure
that the right side wins
and here at cpac we want the p is for
putin so we want putin to win the [ __ ]
now watch we they need our prayers
they they need our prayers who's they
which who is they
if you look at the crowd here the
screenshot
everyone's dumped out there like whoa
whoa whoa we're not gonna get on our
knees
number one mr colin kaepernick get on
your knee we don't get on our knee
anymore we pray with our guns
number one
number one
not one of these
they're not excited at all they're like
yeah ukraine let's pray for those people
nope
no no excitement
none
and not one single person is praying or
down on their knees
single married otherwise really it
doesn't look like it to me and there's a
lot of empty seats did you guys notice
that
well let's continue
there's three people clapping yeah yeah
yeah maybe maybe someone will pray
maybe someone will pray
that zelinski character here we go he's
a hero
that zielinski character
he's a hero he really they're man
they're trying their damnedest they
tried their [ __ ] damnedest this
weekend to
to really try to stand with ukraine like
they they tried so far as to not say it
right they didn't want to say
hey the good guys here are [ __ ]
ukraine the bad guys here are [ __ ]
putin and we're on the side of the bad
guys
we've been on the side of the bad guys
for [ __ ] years
we we are the evil empire
like they that's the reason why they
can't backtrack here and we shouldn't
let them backtrack our messaging in this
country
our messaging in this country is the gqp
is putin's party it's putin's party even
after putin's long gone because i i
don't think putin's got a long time left
here
now we'll see what these negotiations
pan out i think caitlyn was saying here
putin is holding
meetings with government officials about
the russian economy which is uh crashing
into a crater here
it's gonna be abysmal
i mean what what what economy at this
point there's not gonna be an economy
he's get he's gonna crush the russian
people and it's his fault
it's it's his [ __ ] fault did you guys
see this video this guy carrying this um
this land mine
here's the land mine um
everyone sees a 9.7 million everyone's
seen it let's watch it again for those
of you listening
this is a uh ukrainian and he's got he's
got the sig hanging right you know that
you know the sig hang i'm talking about
like you light a cigarette and this
[ __ ] is probably like this is
gonna might be my last [ __ ] chance to
smoke a cigarette so he lights up a
cigarette and that some [ __ ] dangling
off his bottom lip right
and he's carrying a landmine let me
replay this over here he's carrying a
land mine across the road
and he i mean and he looks like he's
carrying you ever carried a a real
steamy pile of dog [ __ ]
like you're holding it out in front of
you you don't really you don't want it
anywhere near you that's kind of what it
seems like here this landmine um
it's
crazy
crazy insane how this guy picks up this
landmine off the road and carries it
down in the dish watch this
let's put the sign on
[Music]
speaking of speaking of dog [ __ ] he's
about to [ __ ] his pants here i mean but
this guy
would you pick up a [ __ ] land mine
i i don't know that i would pick up a
[ __ ] landmine
and carry it across the road
would you holy [ __ ] this guy
this guy's got a set of nuts
look at him
and the guy filming him too really i
mean he's pretty in pretty close
proximity
right
pretty close proximity pack jam says
dude never dropped his cigarette he
didn't drop he didn't drop an ash pack
jam not a [ __ ] ash did he drop off
that cigarette
i i don't know what this guy does for a
living but
he need he he needs to get in the land
mine business this is crazy
absolutely
crazy and he doesn't just carry it a
little bit of rape i mean like he goes
way far away
look at this
crazy son of a [ __ ]
that's pretty [ __ ] awesome that's
pretty [ __ ] awesome i have to say
that is pretty bad
ass
as someone said badassery angela said
badassery
badassery
it's crazy okay let's see if we can go
on to uh
some more stuff here you know we're
we're
30 minutes into the second hour and we
haven't even been to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends yet
um i was trying to see if i could find i
thought i had the video of
of um
wendy rogers now
a bad company here says oh bunker boy
this is a great video by the way you're
gonna want to see this i know a lot of
people don't like to hear this
[ __ ] talk
ron posted here the question of the
reporter is if you were in similar
situation as as president would you take
up arms like z linsky
so as you guys know uh president
zielinski of ukraine he's he's kind of a
they said character earlier he is kind
of a character the guy's like a comedian
actor he was in he was on the dances
with the stars you know ukrainian the
ukrainian version and then he became the
president of ukraine now he's done some
you know things that presidents do in
ukraine i tried to deal with this
corrupt government
um you know because
ukraine is not a perfect democracy by
any stretch of the matter because
democracy is difficult and it takes a
long time for democracy to really get
his feet underneath him but here's the
thing
when the going got tough he got going
he's out there fighting he's out there
with his people the u.s said hey we'll
take you out of the country that way
you're protected he's like nope i don't
need a ride i need weapons
but here trump is asked if he would do
the same thing and of course we know the
[ __ ] answer to this
we know the answer whether he would be
brave or not of course he's not [ __ ]
captain bone spurs would be running for
the hills you've seen the [ __ ] video
where where uh um he's at the podium and
there's some kind of scare in the secret
service he's [ __ ] terrified right
let's watch what this [ __ ] says
oh by the way this is the same guy
i just so you remember i don't know if
you know this or not but this is the
same [ __ ] that told a bunch of
his supporters that went and tried to
overthrow the constitution united states
that tried to try to topple our
government commit a cheeto dust kangaroo
in his name he said he would walk down
to the capitol with him and when they
walked down there he went to his bunker
let's listen situation as president
would you take up arms like kalenski
well you know you never know about
bravery some people think they're brave
and they're not brave enough yeah we
know we know that that's all you need to
know that's all you need to know that's
that you can cut the clip right there
you can cut the clip right there some
people think they're brave and they're
not yet you're not
you're not
you're you're a [ __ ] little [ __ ]
always been a little bone spur [ __ ]
will continue to be that way
for a long time i mean until those
[ __ ] big macs give you a coronary
hopefully all right let's give a bad
company credit here
uh we already gave him credit okay thank
you bad company for posting that and
oh jerry got our the [ __ ] hat
look
thank you jerry
she
she has been waiting for this uh for
this day i'm happy to report my hat made
it even though i typed in the wrong
address
um i i think she got the wrong apartment
number but i'm glad she got her hat
uh thank you for the order and if you
guys want a [ __ ] hat if you guys want
a [ __ ] hat just go to
thetonymichaels.com the link is in the
bio
we have trucker hats we got fitted hats
like i have on here we got t-shirts
um all kinds of good stuff there's
stickers there's two stores there so go
to thetonymichaels.com or the link in
the bio
and you guys can check out the [ __ ]
hats and the merch there that will help
support the the podcast uh here is the
the cheeto dust mobster at cpac i do
want to play this um again um
this is more uh putting in with putin
[ __ ]
yesterday reporters asked me if i
thought president putin was smart
see he's always all blaming on the
reporter [ __ ]
i said
of course he's smart to which i was
greeted with all that's such a terrible
thing to say
i'd like to tell i it is a terror it's a
dumb thing to say because putin's not
smart
like if putin was smart he would have
done a better job at this right i mean
really honestly he would have done a
hell of a lot better job of invading
ukraine but he hasn't and the reason why
is because he's isolated he's isolated
he's delusional
he has no idea that he probably he might
not even know the reason why he's
invading ukraine at this point
it may just be a reflux for that
murderous [ __ ]
yes he's smart
the nato nations and indeed please
please be smart to make sure that you
can launder money to me so that way i
can appear to be rich i hope that putin
is smart i hope he's smart because if
he's not smart i'm really [ __ ] i can't
i won't be able to launder all that
russian money through my through my real
estate holdings that aren't real that
are [ __ ] [ __ ] and aren't valued
what they're valued and i owe so much
money i'm [ __ ] broke and boy it'll be
really hard to appear to be rich if
putin isn't smart it'll really be tough
lead the world
as he
looks over what's happening
by the way i gotta say this guy is this
guy looks more and more like [ __ ] every
day like look at his hair like it used
to be this guy i mean he's got a [ __ ]
shitty haircut in the first place but
this guy used to have you know his hair
uh done up a little different what it's
just it looks like [ __ ] this guy looks
like [ __ ] he looks like he's three big
macs away from a coronary
and i i wouldn't begrudge those [ __ ]
three big necks to be honest with you
strategically
with no repercussions or threats
whatsoever they're not so smart
they're looking the opposite of smart if
you take over ukraine
oh my god what what is he talking about
here to be honest with you what the [ __ ]
is he talking about even the crowd isn't
buying this [ __ ] like this garbage
that he's trying to sell on stage at
cpac
putin's nazi rally i mean putin held the
rally in you in the in
in orlando
putin held this this nazi rally in
orlando he allowed putin allowed trump
to speak at this rally
obviously and this guy can't get into
two words out make a coherent sentence
of why why the crowd should back putin
and they're not even buying it and they
came to the putin rally we're going to
sanction you they say sanction
well that's a pretty weak statement
oh i i wonder i wonder if the let's
let's check in let's check in with the
sanctions
let's check in with the ruble let's
check in with putin to see how those
sanctions are working out for him
let's see how weak they are
let's see how how well this statement
lived the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
this is
can we get more proof of how dumb this
[ __ ] is and how we i can't even
[ __ ] believe that we survived four
years of this dumb son of a [ __ ]
it baffles me every [ __ ] day every
time he speaks i can't believe that this
dumb son of a [ __ ] didn't drive us into
a bigger [ __ ] ditch than we were in
but somehow these people think that if
the the [ __ ] whole world cuts off
russia and putin and they have no money
no money
how that wouldn't be effective
and crash their economy crash the ruble
like their entire population is [ __ ]
broke now
it's [ __ ] broke
as of today the stock market couldn't
even open in russia and the reason why
the reason why grandpa poopy pants here
is bitching about sanctions the reason
why he's bitching about sanctions and
he's so worried about the money that
oligarchs are going to have are not
going to have more importantly it's
because that money isn't going to be
flowing through his washing machine
and if his that oligarch's money that
laundering doesn't happen he doesn't get
to appear rich so of course he's gonna
say that sanctions aren't good sanctions
bad they're not they're weak
because he doesn't want the economic
sanctions
how the hell is he gonna appear to be
rich
true social
they can't even get true social off the
ground like maybe that's why they were
trying to get the true social out so
that they could have a propaganda
machine
to use against ukraine and they couldn't
even get that done devin nunes is in
charge who the [ __ ] puts devin nunes in
charge of anything number one
but number two that guy was so focused
on not not making sure that there was
there wasn't a devin nunes's cow
account that he couldn't even get true
social up and running so that they could
run a propaganda operation against
ukraine
the [ __ ] out of here
putin is saying oh they're going to
sanction me they sanctioned me for the
last 25 years you mean i can take over a
whole country are they going to sanction
me
you mean they're going to blow us to
pieces at least
psychologically
oh you know there's nothing says a lot a
little bit about psychology then your
money ain't worth [ __ ] and oh by the way
even if your money was worth [ __ ] you
can't get to it you can't get it like
it's worth nothing but you still can't
get it you [ __ ] idiots the problem
is not that putin is smart
which of course he's smart but of course
he is uh daddy vlady don't think i think
you're dumb please please please don't
think you're um yeah i think you're dumb
i don't want you to think i'm dumb the
real problem is that our leaders are
dumb
[Applause]
yeah we had some really dumb leaders
that led us to this position like we had
some really stupid [ __ ] in the white
house for four years that led us to this
position where putin's doing what he's
doing i don't know that i can disagree
with that all right let's see uh what
else we got here
oh oh you guys gotta see this
you guys gotta see this speaking of
zelinski
here is uh this has got five million
views i'm not gonna play the whole thing
but here is the president of ukraine
and i'm not sure let's see is this give
a year 2006.
so this is a while ago
um but this is the president of ukraine
on ukraine's version of dancing with the
stars let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
my blue shoes all right all right well
you know he's a pretty good dancer i'm
gonna hand it to him
he's a pretty good dancer and he's good
at defending his country he's good at
defending his democracy
whether it's perfect or not
he is good at it oh this is a good one
um we're 42 minutes into the second hour
we'll get to the tweety tweets in the
trendy trend soon i promise it was a
long timeline from the weekend there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on what do you want me
to do what do you want me to do of
course we cover most of these topics but
we'll get to it here um
liam nissan says dang these days kevin
sorbo is looking like zeus not hercules
look at these pictures for you on on the
audio only kevin sorbo holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] he's gotta been aged like 900
years or some [ __ ] right
that's horrible the guy
wow you guys gotta go look at this
look at this tweet um if you're
listening on the podcast on audio only
you gotta go look at it okay let's go to
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
shall we
shall we let's see what do we have today
um we're 42 minutes 43 minutes into the
second hour and we're just now getting
to the uh the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends what did we have on the
docket for today let me let me double
check
what it was
and then we will um um so we had we had
switzerland we covered that standing
with ukraine stated oh yeah state of the
union's tomorrow by the way dr fauci did
that
um trey gowdy the ruble mueller report
okay let's let's go let's see what's
trending now
uh number one is the batman
let's see
dude switzerland is still trending uh
switzerland again has joined the
european union sanctions against russia
following uh putin's invasion of ukraine
this is really [ __ ] significant i
mean
you talk about you talking about
switzerland like rachel said earlier if
if switzerland is cutting you off holy
you are [ __ ] screwed
like that that's it
that's it now angry staffer says i don't
know if people realize how much russia
money goes through switzerland but
freezing the assets are huge
that's a huge deal
that's a huge [ __ ] deal
that switzerland's like nope sorry [ __ ]
cutting you off
i mean
when you're when you're laundering money
switzerland is usually the place where
you kind of you know you hide money that
you want to hide
whoosh
that's bad it's really bad when
switzerland is calling you out okay
let's go on down um oh new world orders
for me this is the [ __ ] wendy rogers
[ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] wendy rogers [ __ ] uh
let's see if we can find
oh this anti-semitic [ __ ] this nazi
she's a [ __ ] nazi she is a [ __ ]
nazi
this [ __ ] wendy rogers uh talking
about new world order where the hell is
it
where the hell is this wendy rogers
[ __ ]
uh
i think this is it
yeah
wendy rogers wants to talk about new
world order this is rich propaganda from
a woman who seems to think she's better
than a portion of our population why is
an arizona candidate supporting putin
why wendy are you hoping to bring
communism to the u.s
she says the media are a bunch of soros
assets for the new world order what the
[ __ ] are you number one jesus christ
enough of this george soros [ __ ] i
haven't gotten my check no one else has
either george soros if he is paying
everybody he's a [ __ ] deadbeat he
doesn't know how to write out paychecks
he doesn't know how to issue
[ __ ] pay stubs uh she also says the
european union is a new world order
uh tyranny
and germany's attempt to rebuild the
third reich oh [ __ ]
whoosh
whoosh ugh what a bonehead
maybe she'll be on bonehead of the week
uh that seems to be like a possibility
wendy rogers new world er get the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ] uh
dozens killed and hundreds wounded in a
bottoming um i think that's what mj sent
me um let's go to that video mj i've
been holding this video because i
figured we'd get to it um
let's go to that now
here is a
i don't know if this is the same one but
terrell jermaine's star
breaking airstrike hits radar
communications military center
uh five injured uh i'm on the scene i
don't know if this is it this seems like
to be a different one
um
here's the aftermath
all right i'm all right it's true so i'm
just reporting from the scene so a
so the base so the checkpoint where i'm
at
uh there's a military base right across
the street and it was hit with two
missiles and so this is the damage of it
right now so the
military and volunteers are working
to
take care of this situation right now we
were just driving in
when these missiles
struck this base so you're hearing trail
here say that they were driving to the
base and while they were headed into the
base uh the missiles came in and it
looks like it's a nighttime i'm not sure
like what time this is
um we will try to it looks like it was
11 a.m here
uh this morning so this was just about
when we came on the show
um that's central time um
until i get a little bit closer
yeah so this is the damage
so this is apparently apparently from
missiles
30 minutes ago
and this shows you the danger that folks
are in over there um whether they're
journalists or they're ukrainians or
they're helping um there is imminent
danger there as much as we were joking
earlier about the russians not having
capability with some of the tanks and
personnel um they are having some
success um at their murderous ways
and their war crimes
unfortunately
oh man this just this just happened
this just happened
thank you uh terrell for for for giving
us that video and giving us that report
um
let's go back to
where we were
where we were here
um hopefully
[Music]
it's not gonna go back there
sad to see
but we can't look away we must look at
these things um
the other thing too it looks like
uranium one is trending and that
probably has to do with
um
everyone is worried about uh nuclear war
oh uranium one oh this is this is the
hillary [ __ ] i'm not even gonna go there
with the hillary thing i'm not even
gonna [ __ ] do that today maybe we'll
do that tomorrow if it's still trending
uh state of the union obviously tomorrow
we're 49 minutes in the hour
they're reporting biden's team is
revising his first state of the union
address to emphasize russia's unprovoked
invasion of ukraine the new version will
reflect the way the crisis has added
urgency to his long time thinking of
defending democracies
again we actually have a
pro-democracy president it feels good to
have a pro-democracy president because
our former president is absolutely out
there
uh pumping anti-democracy messages by
supporting putin uh let's see
let's go back here what else is trending
turley jonathan turley is apparently
trending i don't know if this guy said
anything of course he did
uh
mark elias says further proof that
turley is essentially mike lindell with
tenure um
jonathan turley says much remains
unknown about judge jackson's in terms
of her judicious philosophy
the fact that we have a
comparable thin record of opinions in
comparison to recent nominees the
question rather we will learn
substantially more than this
confirmation this [ __ ] idiot this
[ __ ] guy's talking about
hitanji jackson brown's nomination
they [ __ ] confirmed her eight months
ago
they did all their due diligence eight
months ago it ain't like she's hadn't
had due diligence done in 20 years get
out of here with this [ __ ] jonathan
turley is a goddamn sycophant
and [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] turley okay the
european union let's see if there's new
news here
um um
that's an hour ago president zielinski
urged the european union on monday to
grant ukraine immediate access to the
bloc now europeans are aware that our
soldiers are fighting for our country
and consequently for the whole world
um so they're wanting they're wanting
membership into the eu it looks like
uh he's urging membership for ukraine
now rather ukraine actually receives uh
admittance into the european union and
nato it will be the question
um here we go the brian reporting here
breaking ukrainian president zalinski
signs application for membership into
the european union
so we'll see how that goes um that could
be a very very tougher blow to putin
even um because his goal was to kill
democracy and it could promote democracy
you see how this works you see how you
see how when when the people and this is
how democracy goes right this is how it
generally [ __ ] goes
you get these [ __ ] fascists that that
don't want democracy that don't want
freedom right you get you get the
the people out there
a little taste of what freedom doesn't
taste like what murderous dictators
taste like
you give them a little taste of that and
they think well maybe democracy ain't
that bad right this is putin's goal is
to make sure to tear down democracy and
he's only promoting it even harder the
world's standing behind democracy here
it's even creating a situation where the
the country the sovereign country of
ukraine which has its problems inside
its democracies they all do
they all do suffer from corruption
but if you think there's not corruption
inside oligarchies and totalitarian
regimes well [ __ ]
uh let's see duty to warn says uh
ukrainian president zielinski has signed
a submitted application same report
so then here's the picture of it here
[Music]
of him signing the application
on this desk
this makeshift desk
inside this what makes looks like a
makeshift supply house
where they're doing operations of war
stark difference stark difference
between him and putin isn't there
he's willing to stand arm and arm
to sign an application to join the
european union
at this small makeshift desk
hmm
i wonder i wonder uh if putin would sit
at this desk i wonder if putin would
sign a document this close to other
individuals i wonder just you know
surmising okay let's go back um so it
looks like uh
we hopefully we'll be able to follow
that news into the week
um rather that application is um
expected uh the women's health
protection act that's trending we're 54
minutes into the hour
and the most radical abortion bill the
united states deceptive named women's
health protection act uh not only pulls
all the federal and state pro-life
laws at risk countless women of unborn
jesus christ the march for life [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
uh patty murphy says today the senate is
voting on the women's health protection
act roe v wade is at stake at the
supreme court we have to act now every
senator who wants people to be able to
make their own decisions
let's listen to republicans have
attacked abortion rights let's listen to
patty murphy
are hanging in the balance at the
supreme court and the threat to rule is
very real
for decades extreme republicans have
attacked abortion rights from every
angle
and they are continuing their non-stop
efforts to build a country where
patients are forced to remain pregnant
and carry their pregnancies to term
against their will but i want to make it
clear that is absolutely unacceptable
because the majority of americans don't
agree with extreme republicans the
majority of americans want a country
where everyone can choose if and when to
start a family
free from political interference
so i will not sit silently while
republicans try to end the abortion
rights affirmed by roe v wade i will
never stop fighting for reproductive
rights and that starts by passing the
women's health protection act to ensure
the right to abortion is finally
protected at the federal level
and i think we must codify all liberties
in this country
the right to an abortion with a person
who is pregnant is one of them
um and we also need to codify more
voting rights in this country to all
people no matter who they are where
they're from
we need to continue to do that so thank
you patty murphy for standing up uh for
women's liberties and [ __ ] you march for
life your [ __ ] tweet sucks i'm gonna
go back and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
them their [ __ ] tweet sucks if i can
find it back here here it is your
[ __ ] tweet sucks you pieces of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yes i want to tweet it twitter i want to
tweet it [ __ ] you right to life
march for life whatever the [ __ ] it is
richard bloom um
it's trending and i had him on the thing
uh is a san francisco businessman
philanthropist and the husband of
feinstein died late sunday the senator's
office tonight so um
dianne feinstein senator dianne
feinstein husband has passed away
um
the los angeles times is reporting
um
did it do
of course we went to the trey gowdy
thing
um
dr fauci let's see what's going for the
for you
um lauren beaubert is now trending oh my
god we're 57 minutes in the hour i don't
even know if i have enough time to click
into this thread let's check it out
though lauren bobert is trending
i'm not sure why we can only imagine
avenger resister sir says lauren brobert
paid someone to take her ged test and
she's
still making payments on it
oh my god
is that this this can't be this can't be
in this game again
um tai says for poisoning my custards to
poisoning my country
lauren bobert's re-election slogan oh ty
thank you very much thank you very much
you guys remember the loose meat
sandwiches you remember that story they
had like a street festival
and lauren bobert's restaurant they put
together some loose meat sandwiches for
people on the street festival and they
all got [ __ ] diarrhea you remember
that
loose meat diarrhea sandwiches okay uh
patriot tate says something here lauren
bro bobert is campaigning with
anthony sabatini a man who once wore
blackface
[Music]
uh oh that's not good that's not good
probably not good
uh where is this guy running at this in
florida probably
i don't know yup holy [ __ ] florida rep
yeah of course
sorry florida sorry
sorry okay let's see here
oh here
this is from cpac this is from fox
nation their little app and their little
app station um the jewish gender
resistor says lauren bobert told fox
nation at cpac canada needs to be
liberated
along with ukraine what this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
she remember was a candace owens were
heard that said we should invade
canada the united states shouldn't make
it you stay out of ukraine united states
but invade canada get the [ __ ] out of
here we also have neighbors to the north
you need freedom
[ __ ] they're still butt hurt about that
[ __ ] convoy speaking of that we got
that interview we're going to play this
week hold hold tight and we still got
you know russian stuff we're dealing
with here and we want to get past the
state of the union but we're going to
play that we're going to play that uh
that interview this week uh for the
trucker uh data dump i got a text from a
canada friend who told me
to keep the crazy [ __ ] out of my
country and i can't stop laughing
oh let's hear what this [ __ ] has to say
i i pray for ukraine and i i wish them
the best they have a great president
right now um who's really said clearly
live free or die yeah [ __ ] you know this
is really funny this is really funny
because they wouldn't have said that
last week they would have said putin
tough putin putin strong putin good guy
go get go get putin need to get freedom
from ukraine ukraine oppressor
i don't need a ride give me ammunition
the fight is right here uh but uh we
also have neighbors to the north who
need freedom and one jesus christ oh my
god
oh god
so she's she's trying to she's trying to
gaslight that canadians need freedom
yeah all you canadians out there don't
you want some more of your that freedom
you ain't got get the [ __ ] out of here
with this [ __ ]
oh my god okay i can't i can't take it
anymore um of course you know i'm
running out of time here and of course
lauren
bobert took up the last five minutes
thank you for joining us here on the on
the [ __ ] list roundup thank you for
joining us on the tony michaels podcast
we have some big announcements coming in
the next week huge huge huge
announcements
so stay tuned every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central right here on youtube
twitter twitch we're gonna we're gonna
share those announcements with you as
they happen this week we have the state
of the union tomorrow night um hopefully
uh
we will we will probably play that
interview on thursday as we wind up
um because we get to we we got the
bonehead of the week on friday we also
we want to do
uh commentary on the state of the union
on wednesday so we'll probably play that
interview on thursday um tomorrow we
want to still follow this ukraine
russian story as
the sanctions happen um as the ruble
falls as putin's russia
crumbles into ashes
and hopefully by the end of the week
putin finds himself in a bunker possibly
possibly epstein
so until tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking